Smartphones have revolutionized how we talk
to each other, play with each other, and help
each other -- so why not how we science each
other?
Let's say science needs your help, or sometimes,
you need science's help -- but who ya gonna
call?
NOT THE GHOSTPEOPLES.
Instead, let's do the science ourselves!
This isn't a new idea.
In 1999 the Search for Extra-Terrestrial Intelligence
released a screensaver that let internet-connected
computers all over the world help SETI churn
through massive amounts of data.
When the computer was idle, the screensaver
would pop up and data analysis would begin!
Simple!
But distributed computing was just one way
citizens could help research and science.
Today, scientists all over the world are beginning
to harness the power of these little computers
we carry in our collective pockets; by crowdsourcing
scientific research.
Accessories are being used to monitor the
movement of bats and birds, map meteoroids,
and track temperatures; and some apps are
even being used to treat depression using
self-help treatments administered via smartphone.
But one of my favorites takes advantage of
something we already do… take pictures of
wildlife.
The Networked Organisms and Habitats project
has an app that lets people take photos of
plants and animals and send it to Project
NOAH for identification!
You can even complete missions, like logging
GPS locations for flocks of birds, or photographing
specific insects near your home.
The camera is a super-power for the smartphone.
Smartphone lenses are built in to the devices
themselves, but often little attachments can
be purchased to add wide-angles, zoom functions
or, in science's case, magnification.
A 3-cent lens was developed for use with smartphones
in classrooms.
Normally, schools have to buy microscopes
for students, and many have to share because
they can cost as much as 10,000 dollars; but
for simple experiments, these lenses allow
up to 120 times magnification, revealing cellular-level
details for less than the cost of a single
text message.
Taking that idea even further, researchers
at the University of California Los Angeles,
developed a tool that allows any smartphone
to analyze DNA!
DNA is tiny, even stretched out it's only
two nanometers long (50,000 times thinner
than a human hair), so the device comes with
a lens to magnify the little bugger.
The lens is housed in a 3D-printed attachment
and pictures can be taken using an app and
the phone's camera!
Then, the app communicates with UCLA's servers
and analyzes the data.
The whole process takes ten seconds and according
to their announcement, "could help diagnose
various types of cancers and nervous system
disorders, such as Alzheimer's, as well as
detect drug resistance in infectious diseases"
while in the field.
Field testing is a huge market for smartphone
accessories, and thanks to another attachment
doctors in Rwanda have been able to test for
potentially deadly viruses like HIV and syphilis
without a lab, or even electricity.
The device, developed by researchers from
more than a half-dozen universities, government
agencies, laboratories and companies, pricks
a finger (like a test for diabetes) and performs
an enzyme-linked immunosorbent assay or ELISA
test using power from the battery in the phone
to run the pumps and analyze the results.
Normally, blood has to be collected and sent
to a lab, but this 34 dollar accessory has
a tiny vacuum chamber, and can accept pre-filled
cartridges of reagents which allow it to automatically
complete the tests in only 15 minutes.
When we add-up all the conveniences for researchers,
it's easy to see how these smartphone accessories
could change science forever.
Do you use any science apps?
Recommend some in the comments!
And if you want to know MORE about some of
the topics we cover here on DNews, check out
my new show TestTubePlus -- where I spend
a whole week on a single science topic!
It's so fun.
Here's an episode from our series about senses,
we have WAY more than five (soundup[a]) Subscribe
to my new show, check it out, tell me what
you think over on Twitter @tracedominguez.
And thanks for the love.